[Musique]
bonsoir à barra tapant kenya merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le choix de repousser d'un mois le
des confinement total est ce que c'est
du bon sens selon vous qui est ce
important est gamin de suivre les
données plutôt que de respecter les
dates comme le dit les données indiquent
que le variant delta et plus contaminant
à hauteur de 50 % donc eu le deviennent
réduire le nombre de cas et dans le même
temps augmenter le taux d'immunisation
il faut également observé s'assurer
observer le pourcentage de quatre filles
et un en hospitalisation
si il y à peu d'hospitalité à sion peu
de cas graves alors on pourrait
éventuellement réouvrir l'apparition du
premier cas remonte au 25 mars dernier
est ce que le gouvernement britannique a
réagi trop tard because tous les
éléments de preuve indiquent que le
pakistan et lepagnot dèche était sur la
liste rouge a raison mais elle n'a pas
été directement mis sur cette veste
rouge et toute personne intelligente
comprend qu'elle n'a pas été mis sur la
liste rouge car le premier ministre
boris johnson avait prévu un voyage en
inde pour rencontrer le premier ministre
muzito lundi 7 c'est regrettable
un mot tout de même sur les vaccins à ce
qu'ils sont efficaces contre le vario
indien je suis heureux de dire que deux
doses de vaccin accorde une protection
significative contre les variants delta
et les autres variantes
il est important de se faire vacciner
aussi rapidement que possible
maxime et autant de personnes que
possible dans toutes les classes d'âge
ce serait une bonne chose alors on croit
aujourd'hui la moitié de la population a
reçu au moins deux doses combien est-ce
qu'il en faudra combien quel est le
niveau à atteindre pour pouvoir
justement permettre à l'économie de ré
ouvrira à 100% cela va être très
compliqué vacciner jusqu'à 75 % de la
population dirais que ils ont en
disposant de limiter collectif c'est une
chose mais lorsqu'on se trouve face à un
variant plus contagieux comme le variant
tel cas il faut atteindre un taux de 85%
de la population vaccinée
c'est une tâche très ardue et à très
onéreuse
tout ce que l'on peut faire c'est
vacciner autant que possible et
surveiller de près le nombre des cas
afin de mettre en place ces des mesures
de contrôle des infections en parallèle
des vaccinations et de la réouverture
mais atteindre un taux d'immunisation et
de 80% à c'est encore très loin
est ce que vous vous diriez que le
royaume uni aujourd'hui fait face à une
troisième vague
c'est la raison du fait que
l'assouplissement des mesures qui a voté
tout prévu pour le 21 juin a été
repoussée d'un mois afin d'éviter la
hausse des cas ce qu'on intègre
également une troisième vague vague
il s'agit de protéger les personnes
encore non vacciner les personnes plus
jeunes et qui s'impose face à marion
plus contagieux alors justement pour
faire suite à ma question 50%
d'hospitalisation en une semaine
est ce que c'est réellement inquiétant
pour faire suite à la question et à
cette troisième vague 5
% d'hospitalisation une semaine est ce
que c'est réellement inquiétant pour le
pays a profondément préoccupés car nous
allons voir si l'augmentation est de 50
% des hospitalisations ensuite passé à
sa 110 80 % il ya toujours un délai de
trois semaines entre l'augmentation du
nombre des cas et l'augmentation du
nombre d'hospitalisations les trois
prochaines semaines seront déterminantes
montreront si les vaccins préviennent
les hospitalisations ou si l'on peut
tous des mondes finir hospitalisés
d'accès ou non donc les trois semaines à
suivre seront très important qu'il
faudra vraiment voir ce qui va arriver
au niveau des hospitalisations
alors vous avez peut-être entendu tout à
l'heure les indications de notre
ministre de la santé 2 à 4% de variants
indien enregistré en france est ce que
nous on doit s'inquiéter selon voit
effectivement c'est inquiétant l'union
européenne ou le royaume uni
le monde entier tout cela ne représente
qu'une seule grande famille ce qui
arrive au royaume uni finira par arriver
en europe et dans le reste du monde
il faut vacciner vacciner aussi
rapidement que possible et en parallèle
à protéger les populations grâce au
contrôle de la propagation notamment
dans les espaces clos afin d'éviter la
contamination
merci beaucoup à vous baratin gagnage
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université à
des casseurs